[Applaudissements]
vous souvenez-vous de nos premiers
instins souvenez-vous le temps du
premier
rendez-vous vous souvenez-vous de nos
premiers moments en ce temps je vous
disais
vous et le temps passait et je te
disaisv bien sûr toi tu pensais combien
de temps seou et le temps passait sans
que je dise tu tu m'impressionnis tant
tes
plis ce sourire d'ange ses yeux
émerveillés tes sais en rayonnés de
beauté face à ce
chedvre ma
timidité alors mettez-vous à ma place se
mais il fallut bien que m'échappe le tu
qui fit qu'un jour enfin de vous tu
devintu mais il fallut bien que je range
mes vous pour que toi et moi fasse
[Musique]
l'
pour un grand voyage l'on s'est embarqué
comme elle passe vite les
années malgré les nuages qui peuvent
passer je ne vous laisse pas ma
place il advient parfois que je te dise
vous quand tout ne va pas bien pas pas
très bien entre nous mais n'y crois pas
et tu parles de nous alors sans est F d'
vous